[Music]
yeah as I got mentioned my name is Usain
and I'm gonna be talking today about
performance empathy
now empathy is a term we commonly used
to describe the ability to understand
and share the feelings of another
individual or a group I like to think of
the term performance empathy to be the
same thing before the performance
concerns and issues of a particular site
to sort of explain why I thought it
would be a good topic for a talk I need
to first describe a bit more about
myself
I work as an advocate for the web team
at Google now developer advocates and
many different companies usually act as
sort of a bridge between a specific
engineering community and the specific
engineering team and a developer
community but being advocates for the
web team means that it's my job to make
sure the web gets better and better I
focus on speed and performance so a lot
of Advocates we sometimes give advice
that can seem a little overwhelming I
don't know why my clicker feels weird
they go
but in all seriousness why are so many
performance advocates so fascinated
about what many people do with their own
tool chains why are we so focused on
whether it will improve performance or
not why do we care about performance
that much to begin with is it really
that much of a problem to help us answer
this question let's take a look at this
example of a site it's an entirely
client-side rendering site that ships
about a megabytes of render blocking
JavaScript and when I say client-side
rendered this means that the initial
request only contains a shell of an HTML
document only after they use it only
after the JavaScript bundle finishes
executing the user gets to see any real
content now in case you weren't counting
the amount of time it took for this app
to finish loading was about 19 seconds
19 seconds isn't fast by any means so we
know that one megabyte of JavaScript can
seem like a lot to ship down to browsers
how much are we generally shipping if we
take a look at HTTP archive we can see
that the median amount of JavaScript
that we're sending down the wire it's
about 350 kilobytes and this is from
mobile web pages the reason why this is
such a big deal is was there's a lot of
web sites currently living in the web
that are either entirely static or to
have little to no interactivity at all
so I thought it'd be interesting to dive
in a little deeper and see how much
sites that use a particular framework or
shipping in terms of JavaScript and I
did it with three frameworks to begin
with angular react and view and the
reason why I chose d3 is because of the
most popular client-side frameworks that
we use today to build out our uisce what
I found out was after querying over
250,000 origins about 50% of them
shipped over a megabyte of JavaScript
now each of these origins either use one
or more of these frameworks there's a
lot of reasons why this might be the
case but it does show that we are
shipping a lot of JavaScript if we're
not entirely careful
now what I want to do now is take a step
back and talk about how I began this
presentation you see every single talk
of ever given before today has always
followed the exact same format I begin
with a word of caution and talk about
how our performance is a pretty big
problem I then move on to showing some
stats and some numbers to back up my
claim and I do this to convey how much
of a problem this actually is and then
the rest of my talks usually followed
the same sort of same sort of pattern
where I talk about different tips
different techniques that you should be
applying to make sure your site stays as
small as possible and as fast as
possible but for this talk I'm going to
go in a slightly different direction I'm
going to talk about what we can do with
advocates and what we could do better to
reach the community better as well as
how we can all work together to try to
think of different ways to make sure
performance is a win for everybody going
back to that example of a site that we
just talked about here I mentioned that
at the very end I mentioned that we're
running this on a mobile device and on a
slow 3G connection the reason why I
mentioned is a lot of people trace
performance they try to talk about
specific user conditions that might not
be the same as yours when you build your
application and we do this because it's
depending on the user's device depending
on the user's network type they can
experience your site a lot slower than
you think and there's more we sometimes
talk about how your users might
experience your site if they're
completely offline or if they have a
flaky network connection or maybe they
have a weaker device or maybe they're on
mobile so forth and so on
although these it is important to talk
about all these scenarios and try to
capture different conditions your users
might be in the thing I want to make
sure I mentioned is that you know your
users better than anyone else
you definitely know your users better
than any advocate that stands on stage
telling you how well your site performs
under a certain condition but that being
said one thing I also want to mention
is the fact that nobody prioritized
performance over anything if you think
about it when you're trying to build a
site the very first thing you're
thinking about usually isn't performance
most people are like this but if you
also think about it
why should someone make it the very top
thing they think about let's talk about
some scenarios to try and explain what I
mean here say you wake up one Monday
morning and you have an amazing idea
you've thought about a product that you
want to sell on the website or maybe you
want to provide a specific type of
service so you're excited and the next
thing you Natura lis do is you try to
find out how to build it you spent a
little time researching the tools the
tips the tricks that you need maybe
you're building wireframes maybe
building graphics so forth and so on but
only after that you actually start you
actually start building and at this
point throughout this initial process
nobody really thinks about performance
the one the thing that you're actually
most likely thinking about is the fact
that you want to build a site that loads
and does exactly what you expect it to
do but build it with as minimal effort
and as fast as possible a second
possible scenario could be the fact that
you join a brand new team as a developer
save the late the newest developer on a
brand new company or a brand new team
and when you get assigned your first
tickets you're most likely going to try
and familiarize yourself with the
codebase you're going to spend a little
time trying to know where your
components live where the utilities live
how do unit tests work so forth and so
on and only after that why are you doing
that you start building and working on
your first feature maybe it's a small
feature you're adding on a page maybe
it's a small bug that you're working on
but again also when you're in these
shoes you're not really thinking about
performance you're not thinking about
okay I need to make sure what I'm
building doesn't really degrade the
performance of my site no and this is
the first thing you're doing you're most
likely trying to check every single box
that's assigned to you and it's highly
unlikely performance is on that list
so the way I like to think about
awareness and performance in general and
how people are aware of the performance
implications on the site I try to think
of it as in some sort of scale for
example let's say you're building
something for the first time or you're
building something for the up teens time
but you're learning a brand new tool
what you're going to be doing at this
point is going to try to see how this
Tool Works doesn't do what you expect it
to do you want to learn this API learn
that it is easy to plug into your site
but at this point it's highly unlikely
you're thinking of how badly it's gonna
affect performance
no you're most likely thinking how is it
it how easy is it for me to use let's
say you spend some more time with it and
after a while you end up launching your
first website with it now you have a
better idea of how it works in
development mode and how it works in
production mode so now you have a much
better feeling of letting it really it's
affecting performance or not but you
still might be slightly unsure of what
you need to do about it but the more and
more you use this tool and the more
websites you build with it the more
familiar you are with how it effects the
speed and reliability of your site but
that being said nobody is more aware
with the fact they named Amy to work on
performance than those that actually
know they have issues if a significant
percent of your user base tells you that
we can't access your site because it's
too slow you're most likely going to try
and prioritize it as soon as possible
and this is what I mean my performance
being an afterthought but maybe there
are ways out there for forms not to be
something we only think of when it's too
late
throughout this talk I sort of had this
dichotomy between two different user
groups one being performance advocates
like myself and one being a normal
developer working in a team working on a
regular codebase
now advocates I think we all agree on
the fact that there are way too many
slow sites and the reason why I think
this this is true is because we have our
job because a lot of the sites out there
aren't as fast as they should be if
every user acts as the website and felt
like it was fast as it needed to be we
wouldn't need to be doing what were you
do every day but there's another
misconception or
not a thought that sometimes gets
misconstrued that seems kind of weird
and it's the idea that developers are
sloppy when they ship slow experiences
and I've seen the sentiment time-to-time
and I and I can't stand it because if a
developer is working on a website and it
happens to be too slow
it's usually one of three reasons one
they know they don't know it's too slow
for their users two they know it's too
slow for some of their users but they
don't know how to fix it or they haven't
prioritized that yet and three they know
it's too slow and they're actively
working to fix speed again is always
relative and having an advocate tell you
that you're not focusing on something
very important to them isn't always the
best approach now on the other side of
the coin when we talk about a developer
when you're building a website you're
most likely going to agree that you have
a million things you can work on
performance is just one of them but
there's also another weird thought that
I also see sometimes floating around and
it's the idea that advocates or
performance advocates specifically are
out of touch and the reason why some
people might think this is because of
the fact that many performance advocates
will build small sample apps and short
show you how to optimize but some people
feel like it's not as easy to try to do
it with a massive codebase and a massive
team where code is being checked in
everywhere the reason why I sort of want
to squash this thought is because
advocates have been in your shoes we are
developers when works with teams you
understand that is more concerns to site
then there is chefs performance so
instead of having this back and forth
between small weird opinions and small
small thoughts I think it's safe to say
that we all agree towards one common
goal we all want the web to be faster
for everyone so the big question is how
can we make sure we can fix the
performance but the promise problem
better
so I'm gonna talk about a few ways we're
trying to explore advocates that are
changing sort of how we think about
making things better for our developers
the very first is making sure everybody
has better defaults or what I mean by
default is the idea that let's say
you're building something with a certain
tool
if for if it always you have gives you a
better starting point you'll most likely
always have more wiggle room and more
room to play with where it'll take you
longer to meet your threshold or
performance ends up being slow and in
terms of framework level other
frameworks are looking into this all
right
react it's already been looking into
trying to improve react arm and make his
bundle size smaller and they're doing it
through a few different ways one of them
being simplifying its advanced system
with view and view three they're aiming
to reduce memory consumption and cut
down its initial bundle size but maybe
things more tree shakable where they
can't and the angular team is looking
into buildings new is brand new
rendering engine called ivy and whether
they're already exploring ways to cut
down a special bundle size and also
looking at ways or maybe progressively
hydrating experiences when you have
server render architectures reacts and
suspense is also doing the same thing
and then there's meta framers things
like next Jas and noxious that build on
top of frameworks like reactive view
that allow you to continue to do what
you most likely want to do all the time
right and build your components there
are the things we tell people to do
quite often you should be code splitting
you should be server rendering where you
can and these many frameworks try to
take it take it out of the hands of the
developer we're already working with an
XJS to trying to see if we could do
things even better and even have smaller
bundle sizes and make sure users get the
best experience whenever they can when
we talk about defaults and all the way
to think about it too is also the
default api is or the out-of-the-box API
is that the browser provides it will be
a lot easier if we didn't have to
leverage third-party libraries or write
scripts ourselves when we try to
optimize things that the browser can
probably do already an example of this
is the lazy loading attribute now if
anybody here has actually built
something with a lot of images you most
likely realize that having a lot of
images load at once can affect
performance
so people have become quite used to
either pulling in a third-party library
or writing their own custom script it
takes advantage of the intersection of
driver API or scroll event listeners to
only load images as the user Scrolls
close enough to them the loading
attribute is someday that's going to be
rolled out to Chrome pretty soon and
buying using it with any image tag or
iframe tag it'll automatically lazy load
images after reaches a certain distance
threshold from the bottom of the
viewport think about the winds this can
make twenty developer think about the
main developers that don't either know
how to build their own lazy loading
script or don't even know if that's if
there's such a thing but once they
realize there's a simple loading
actually they can add it will make
things a lot simpler for everybody
another example of an API that also can
make things easier is the virtual
scholar API that's also being worked on
right now and if you've ever built
anything with a variable site with long
array long table or very large list
you've also also realized that having
all those dominoes populate at once can
affect rendering performance and the
idea behind list virtualization or
virtual scrolling is to make sure that
only the nodes or only the items on the
list that the user can see is populated
to the DOM and as the user Scrolls down
those Dom nodes get recycled with newer
dominoes a lot of frameworks like react
like angular have third-party libraries
that allow you virtualized lists but
having a baked in API can mean you can
do this without relying on any of them
at all they're also looking for things
they can a lot of these libraries don't
even take into account just yet
for example accessibility concerns or
the fine on-page feature or how could se
o crawl your page or how can a crawl or
crawl your page and detect things
they're not rendered as Dom just yet
another very important thing that we
also realize is in general we need
better guardrails
for all developers will notice a pattern
where we tell people to optimize a lot
of teams will go ahead and they'll start
doing something but that's a certain
period of time feature creep scope
creeps then new features are being added
new code is being shipped and they
regress either to their initial States
or to the state worse than they were
prior
so idea buying guardrails is what if you
had something that made sure everybody
stayed accountable and make sure
everybody stayed on a narrow path one
such example of a guardrail is a
performance budget and then you're
buying a performance budget is it's a
budget for a certain performance metric
that you make sure your app never
exceeds there's many tools out there
they can allow you to add performance
budgets one such example that was
recently launched was something called
light wallet now light house is an
open-source tool built by the chrome
team that allows you to audit how well
your webpage is doing and it allows you
to test it along a few Lori's office its
accessibility it's SEO its performance
and so on a lot of developers already
use lighthouse every day and your
tooling workflow and then you're buying
light wallet is what if you can just
specify a single JSON file to add
performance budgets into it so you can
specify different resource types define
the budget that you should never exceed
as well as define third-party or all
requests and make sure the number of
requests never exceeds a certain value
the third the third most important point
and I think this is something that
actually resonates me with me quite well
is the fact that we need to meet
developers where they are now as
advocates if we're telling developers
that they need to change their entire
workflow or the tools that they're using
isn't going to work and they have to
swap it out for another we're not going
to go very far and it's something I've
seen more and more of right now
so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to improve the fact that whatever tool
you decide to use whatever framework you
decide to use whatever live we decide to
use what if we can always make sure that
tool stays performant as it possibly can
in terms of how we're trying to do this
one way is through tooling and as a
feature called stack backs this also
extends lighthouse but in a slightly
different way
the idea behind stack backs is it
actually allows lighthouse to detect
what tools are being run in your page
and then it will also surface additional
recommendation more specific to that
tool for example let's say you're using
WordPress to build a site and you're
trying to figure out how to properly
sighs images you can read a highly
generalized advice that will apply to
anyone but you'll also see advice that's
more specific to you you'll figure out
how to do it using the WordPress
platform now with the idea of stack
packs we're trying to roll this out to
many JavaScript frameworks and other CMS
tools to make it easier for as many
developers as possible WordPress is the
only one that's actually supported right
now documentation is always going to be
a big deal it's going to be a big deal
for a while now in Google II and in the
chrome team we have a lot of
documentation that's very high level
very generalized and they work for the
main developers as they possibly can but
one thing we're also trying to do is I'm
trying to roll out frameworks specific
guidance web dev is a new documentation
site that we have it's more interactive
and more specific to the user and
recently launched a whole section on
frameworks the idea is we're not the
idea here is we're not trying to teach
you how to use a tool like react we're
trying to show you how you can make your
react app as fast as possible using
inbuilt react API and third-party
libraries in the react ecosystem we
found having more like angular view and
other frameworks in the future one other
thing that chrome team has also been
doing is in terms of monetary support
Malta and Nicole announced this at CES
and they mentioned something called a
framework fund and the idea here is
there's a lot of people working in
open-source there's a lot of developers
working an open-source and one thing
that they focus on is performance and
how perform it those tools are but what
if we could support them when more than
one way more than one way than one so
that they can continue to try improve
performance of their tools so every user
decides to use them or automatically get
better defaults better guardrails and
more so when it comes to fixing the
performance problem I think as advocates
we're currently doing it in two sort of
ways one being what I call external
support we write blogs to tell you how
to do things we build third-party
libraries that you can plug in to your
site we give talks at a place like J's
comp and tell you what you need to do to
improve the speed of your site and then
there's their internal side of things
how about the tools that you're using
gets better
default what if they get better at a
starting point what if they have better
budgets what are they having better got
a better guidance and better warnings as
of now I currently feel like we're more
so on the external side and that's fine
we'll continue to do that as long as you
can reach more developers as we possibly
can but what I'd like to see in the next
few years is a shift in the other
direction
in an ideal world we wouldn't have to
tell developers what to do if every tool
they're using already does it
automatically I hope you enjoyed this
talk as much as I enjoyed giving it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]